and minimalists hello simpleton what's
up y'all
welcome to minimus podcast we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua Fields
Milburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists well
these are trying times right yeah and
and the stock market is in a freefall at
the time of this recording yeah we're
gonna talk about the economy today we're
gonna talk about what it means to live
in trying economic times a lot of us are
living paycheck to paycheck a lot of us
can't scrounge enough money for an
emergency we don't have emergency funds
we're not saving for retirement we are
in times that are really challenging
financially and we'll talk about what
that means and who better to talk about
that with than our good friend TK
Coleman our economist expert or MVP so
CK you you're with me the foundation for
economic education your directive over
there and and so you understand a lot
about economics and so I wanted to to
talk today try to live up to that
billing well we really have some
questions from our audience this is a
listener driven show so I thought I
would just dive right into some of these
questions our first one is from Jim and
floss more Illinois I'm interested
maximizing my standard of living my
wealth and quality of life while
minimizing the cost associated with
living so I want to make sure I have the
maximum amount of wealth and quality of
life and standard of living as possible
while minimizing the cost of living is
minimalism a good strategy for this it
sounds to me like what Jim is asking
here is its coffin week we actually
conflate wealth with well-being and we
can we conflate net worth with
self-worth and these are two separate
things it doesn't mean you have to be
against money to be to be for well-being
but when we just put money first or we
think it's the only part of the equation
then we I think we run into trouble and
we noticed this on a broader scale too
with the economy at large we we have
when we are focused only on the stock
market for example maybe the stock
market isn't isn't the best measurement
for for wellbeing necessarily yeah yeah
I agree let's talk to Jim about this so
how does minimalism help his well-being
how does it help his and input in part
and part of our income and part of our
net worth I would argue that up to a
certain extent does help our our
well-being and I think with minimalism
like what the first thing I thought of
was how I have taken this philosophy of
mindfulness of living deliberately of
whatever you want to call it whatever is
Amin won't you want to put behind it
mariah and i we're debt-free and i'm not
saying that you have to be debt-free to
be a minimalist but that is that is what
Mariah and I have strive for in
simplicity and being deliberate has
gotten us there and I'll tell you that
this with the coronavirus yeah like Josh
and I we've got SEP IRAs I've got money
in betterment with index funds
I even have like you know some
individual stocks that I have played
around with with Tesla I don't want to
go into the amount of money that I've
lost over the last you know month or
maybe just two weeks even it's been an
appreciable amount I'm talking like it's
just a lot so I can look in the mirror
though and I can say because I'm
debt-free
I don't have to sit here and worry about
going out and making as much money as I
can them to make all these debt payments
I can I can truly look at it and I can
and I am privileged enough I want to I
want to be very clear that I recognize
how how fortunate and how privileged I
am to look in the mirror and say it's
just money and I and I think that is
where this what was his name Jim I think
this is where Jim is trying to get he's
trying to get to a point where money is
not a stressor for him it sounds like
maybe it's stressing him out right now
and sometimes when we feel that stress
we start to put money first and we start
to make that you know our number one
problem but if we like Josh said if we
make that our number one problem well
now we're just introducing a lot more
problems I'm not a millionaire I know
some though and they tend to stress out
more about money than most people I know
yeah
a check to pay check and so the amount
of money that you make doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to stress
more or less about money is that fair TK
100% 100% and and you know it sounds
like Jim is looking for some advice on
hey what can I do in order to like
minimalize the right things and also you
know optimize my life I think the first
thing I would say is your financial plan
ought to be an extension of your life
mission in the same way that your
fitness plan should be an extension of
your your health mission so let's say
you go to the gym and you hire a fitness
trainer and I'm in the role of the
fitness trainer I'm not gonna start by
saying I want you to you know do so many
laps around the track where I want you
to spend so much time on the treadmill I
should start with why are you here what
do you want and your goal may be I want
to prepare for a marathon
it may be man I got a wedding in two
weeks and I just want to fit into this
tux real nicely and the particular
mission that you have will dictate what
it is I'm gonna tell you you need to do
you know coupled with some understanding
of the sacrifices that you're willing to
make and so I think it's very important
when you're thinking about how should I
manage my finances that you don't follow
cookie cutter advice like save this much
invest this much because that's all
gonna be based on what your mission is
and sometimes and I'm not accusing you
of this Jim but sometimes the desire for
a lot of money can actually be a way of
being lazy because if I can just say I
want a million dollars that means I
don't have to think critically about my
desire lifestyle and I don't have to
quantify my dreams and economic terms I
can just use a million dollars as a
proxy for enough money to do whatever I
want and now I don't have to think about
what I wanted now I can just sit on my
couch and pay people to do everything
for me yeah yeah I love where you
started with the the health plan that's
the question that Jim needs ask himself
where is he trying to get with his
financial situation if he's trying to
have you know a Bill Gates house and a
private jet and all that okay I mean I
would argue that you don't need that to
live a meaningful life but maybe that's
what it takes for Jim the great outline
what that money is going to get you
because he can't I fell in that trap
dude when I was in the corporate world I
used to tell myself one day I'll just
have a million dollars you know I'm
you're gonna work towards having a
million dollars in the bank account and
when I have a million dollars in in the
bank account I'll be able to work when I
want I'll be able to go on vacations
I'll be
to buy a new car when I want I'll be
able to you know afford a nice house but
here's the thing is what I've realized
over the last you know 10 15 years I can
do all those things and I don't need a
million dollars to do those things I am
also not a millionaire and it's it's
interesting how I'd I pretty much travel
when I want I work when I want I can do
all these things but I don't have
anywhere near a million dollars here's
the biggest fallacy with that as well
because I had the very similar goal of
this arbitrary goal and the thing was
once I got a million dollars or if it
was the promotion that I want once I
become the senior vice president or once
I become CEO Oh then and only then will
I give myself permission to be happy as
opposed to you we say the hata the the
the pursuit of happiness but what about
the happiness of pursuit and and quite
often we don't we we put ourselves
through all this misery and discontent
because we think immediately I'm gonna
be able to give myself permission to be
happy when I make that million dollars
or I get the promotion or I I finish
writing the book or whatever it might be
as opposed to enjoying that I mean it's
it's it's so it's become cliche to say
enjoy the journey but cliches are
cliches for a reason platitudes are
platon to Donnell for a reason is
because we we realized some deep
fundamental level that I can be happy
right now and in fact I'm gonna be much
happier because as I pursue finishing
the book or getting the money or
whatever it might be
I'm not waiting for that that a switch
to flip because it will flip and I'll
feel that that momentary burst of
happiness but then I'm going to feel the
deep deep emptiness because it wasn't
everything that I thought I was going to
be if you rely on a number to make you
happy there's just going to be another
number that takes its place now I want
to be I want to differentiate between
like having a number as an oh I need a
million dollars to be happy and not
really know why however let's say you're
saving up for I don't know you need an
operation and you're like if I can get
this $12,000 saved up I can finally get
this operation that's going to increase
the quality of my life well but that's
the endgame is getting
the operation so you can again you know
go on the pursuit of happiness or enjoy
that pursuit of happiness but even
though even in that scenario you're the
endgame isn't happiness it is being able
to move forward and still pursue
happiness so again if you're looking at
a number and saying well that number is
what is going to make if 2 million
Twitter followers which I haven't got
there yep and maybe that is happiness -
there's a million Twitter followers well
yeah I mean go I mean this this
correlates where Josh is really a point
like you've got to think about wealth in
a holistic way so you know for instance
if you prioritize money over meaning too
much let's say you get a job offer
that's on the table and job a doesn't
really pay you that much but enough to
kind of survive if you make some
sacrifices job D pays you a lot more
maybe I can optimize my life
but what if job a allows you to work in
a company culture that really enriches
your soul what if it allows you to work
around people that are really creative
and that inspire you and help bring out
the best in you
right and if you if you're prioritizing
money too much well then you can make
the money decision but then that will
also be your ceiling that will also
leave you stressed out all the time
it'll compromise your creativity whereas
you can take the meaning path and
that'll make you a better human being
and you might be able to create more
options for yourself over the next you
know three to five years so prioritize
meaning over money and don't follow any
financial plan until you have first
thought critically about what the good
life means to you because maybe you can
live in Kentucky or maybe you got to
live in New York two different financial
plans for those people 100% yeah
especially living in LA it's like you
know I can't afford a nice house in Los
Angeles but I'm okay with that I mean
it's yeah I can still you know afford to
live in a very comfortable situation but
it made me think to Tk hey if you want
to make a quick forty thousand dollars
go to Thailand put yourself on a kidney
transplant list don't buy your kidney
for forty thousand dollars but what are
you giving up what are you giving up for
forty great I mean I can't I I saw this
article where this dude with the he sold
is he sold his kidney and he end up
buying like an iPhone in a car with it
or something I'm like that's yeah let's
let's not do that people ya know
obviously I'm joking do not do that yeah
book recommendation yeah Michael
Ellsberg the last safe investment very
great book for thinking about
asset accumulation that goes beyond you
know the traditional financial markets
how to cultivate your own potential how
to realize the wealth within and know
not in some metaphysical kind of way but
in a very pragmatic skills-based way
Sean can you put a link to that book in
the show notes also Jim I'm going to
send you a copy of our book actually our
book essential it's an essay collection
with twelve different areas of
attentional living one of those is
getting your finances straight because
if where you are in debt it's really
difficult to to pursue freedom if you
are tethered to something right just by
definition if you're tethered to
something you're not going to be free if
the if debt is a giant anchor in your
life or an anchor at all I would argue
that any debt is bad that there's no
such thing as good debt there's an
entire finances chapter in our book
essential 12 different areas of
intentional living if you like our
podcast you really like the audiobook
version of essential it's over six hours
long or if you want the book book or the
eBook version we'll be happy to send
those to you as well Jim our next
question is from Holly in Quincy
Illinois I've been doing a lot of
research on personal money management
and saving for retirement including
checking out all the great resources you
have on your website the work full-time
for a church and do a little bit of
substitute teaching as well and I'm a
gross income of about 31 thousand a lot
of the items you recommend on your
website sometimes are out of my week
even practicing a minimalist lifestyle
so my question is what recommendations
would you give for managing finances
savings retirement etc for a person with
a modest income so Holly
first off Bravo to you for asking
important questions here because what
you're really asking about is how do I
take the limited resources I have and
use them to the best of my ability
you're talking about minimalism and and
I often will say that your when Ryan and
I we grew up really poor but then
throughout our 20s we made really good
money in the corporate world right we we
as we made more money though that
amplified our bad decisions because we
had more resources to to then support
our bad decisions
and what holiday is saying here is that
some of the things that we recommend our
website are out of reach for her I wish
she was more specific on that iid like
I'm trying to like really rack my brain
to like books or like that's why I
thought that's what I thought at first
but I think what would the way I took it
and again I wish is what she said
something as specific is the practices
that we talk like we talked about hey
saving twenty bucks a week like there
are certain recommendations we have but
yeah but it but even a book though
that's that's where my first thought
went but I'm like we've never
recommended a book that was you know
more than twenty bucks or worth and free
more than prayer exactly and and so
Holly what I would say sometimes we come
up with these excuses on our own mind
saying I'm unable to do X because I'm
not the type of person or I can't afford
it or whatever we're talking about
minimalism minimalism is free living in
why is it free because living
intentionally is free now can you be a
multimillionaire minimalist yeah I would
argue that the Kanye West lives in a
minimalist home even though it's a sixty
million dollar mansion because there's
intention that goes into that do you
need a sixty million dollar home to be a
minimalist obviously not you can live in
an RV you can live in a one-bedroom
apartment
it's about being intentional with the
resource you have so you're asking the
right question but you're saying okay I
make $31,000 a year can I be a
minimalist on that well I can tell you
from personal experience I lived in the
corporate world and made really good
money I walked away from that first year
I walked away I made $23,000 that year
and I was more financially secure making
$23,000 I not said it had to make some
sacrifices I had to get rid of some
things that I otherwise would have paid
more money for but I was more
financially secure why because I took
personal responsibility and said my time
is worth more than the money I'm gonna
spend on the things I don't necessarily
need and so whether you make $31,000 a
year or three hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year or 31 million dollars a
year we can all benefit from being more
intentional being more delivered with
the resources that we have yeah take a
cue from all of the negative things in
your life it's not the dramatic stuff
that kills you it's the
that compound over time and that same
principle also applies to wealth
creation you know there's a verse in the
Bible that says despise not the day of
small beginnings I think the reason we
fail to make progress isn't because we
lack financial resources or social
connections but we lack the faith to
believe in the power of small actions
small actions that can compound over
time and produce a dramatic impact so if
you're ever in a position where it seems
like getting started is not feasible for
you it's probably because your starting
point is too big so um if someone that
you deeply love and respect says save
twenty dollars a week and you for
whatever reason can't afford to set
aside $20 a week don't stop there don't
use that as an excuse to not save at all
because you can't afford to do the $20 a
week bring that starting point down
customize for yourself think for
yourself and say all right
the underlying principle here is the
habit of saving so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna bring that number down to five
dollars a week even if it's only two
dollars a week it's about the signal
that you're sending to the universe it's
about the mindset that you're
cultivating and you can have it your
cultivating as well absolutely the
principles of investing a million are
the same as as investing a dollar
the risks are higher but it still takes
the same mindset to create the wealth so
even if you got to bring that number
down to $1 don't be afraid to smoke so
start small
the second thing just in case you are
talking about information like not being
able to afford books whatever may be
here's a little trick that works in this
day and age that I didn't have the
luxury of knowing 20 years ago find the
author's name for any book or any
resource that maybe you can't afford to
buy and just go to youtube and pull up a
whole bunch of podcast episodes and
talks where they're riffing on that book
and you'll get the essence of most of
their philosophy from those sources take
advantage of what you can and don't use
what you can't do as an excuse for not
getting started do those are those are
two great points the the thing I would
out here with Holly is is like it sounds
to me and if I'm wrong Holly you tweet
me and tell me I'm dead wrong but it
sounds to me like Holly doesn't have a
budget and it might be because she feels
like and I've had many mentees who say
I'd say get a budget and they're like
well I don't need a budget Ryan to know
how poor I am that is that is the worst
attitude that you can have because if
you don't know how poor you
well then you're never going to pull out
of it so Holly I highly recommend you
come up with a budget go go - every day
is it every dollar calm yeah yeah so you
go to every dollar calm you get the app
every dollar and then our other
budgeting tools out there pick your
favorite one personally me and Mariah
use every dollar we use the free version
there is a pro version that makes it a
little easier to to manage like things
that come into your bank account you can
kind of sort them if you get the free
version if to manually input everything
I like manually inputting everything cuz
it forces me to use the app and it
forces me to stay close to it but what
will happen Holly is that you'll be able
to look at a where all your money is
going that's the first step to being
more deliberate figuring out where every
single dollar is going every dollar and
then once you are once you are using
that app now you now you are starting to
feel the pain like right now with Mariah
and I with our budget any time that we
are getting ready to go over on a
certain item what we're getting close to
going over we there's a pain that we
feel before I even think about going out
and we're gonna go see the movies and
it's like well we only got like 60 bucks
left on our on our entertainment budget
you have to make some decisions yeah and
there's a week left and man those that
movies phormium rai is gonna cost 40
because in l.a costs 20 freakin dollars
to go see a movie it's like man that's
gonna be that's gonna be you know 66
percent of what we have left like it
forces you to make tough decisions it
forces you to change your state and
Holly that's what you got to do you have
to find ways to change your state are
you gonna be able to save you know that
thousand dollar emergency fund that Dave
Ramsey talks about in Total Money
Makeover no you're not gonna be able to
save that right away but like TK said
you can start saving towards that I had
this dude email me from Belfast D I talk
about him a lot and I always bring him
up because he is a fighter like he is
just someone who he does not give up and
I've never
he's just the perfect example if someone
who doesn't give up the dude he is a he
is a literally a fighter he's a boxer
and he goes out of his way to be this
almost a starving artist cuz he coaches
and he also boxes like he's kind of the
dude that goes into the ring and they
they beat the crap out of him like when
they need someone to be the crap out of
but he loves it he loves to fight but
the guy is like he's really
not financially super secure but he even
emailed me he's like Ryan he's like mint
and what you you know there's a certain
podcast episode or something where he
was like you challenged someone like me
to save a thousand dollars and he was
like I saved it so much faster than what
I thought I would be able to but but
just having the attitude of you know
what I am gonna I am gonna go ahead and
do this I'm gonna challenge myself to
save at the husband dollars he was able
to do it pretty quickly and the
financial security that he has from that
just being able to afford you know an
emergency expense that costs up to a
thousand dollars that actually has taken
a lot of stress off of his life he's
still he's still fighting he's you know
he's not a millionaire it's not like
he's pulled himself out of everything
but it's these little things that he's
able to do to just release some of that
financial stress and Holly you can do
the same exact things two things here
because you bring up the thousand
dollars and TK brings up these
principles they work whether you have a
dollar or a million dollars and so we'd
be remiss if we didn't bring up some
principles here we are ourselves are big
fans of Dave Ramsey
we've been on his show we've had his
entire team on our show in fact I was
just texting with Anthony no
neilandchris Hogan just yesterday about
some stuff and we're gonna send you a
copy of the Total Money Makeover it's
one of the few books I buy by the case
but I wanted for the folks who are
listening here just we'll go over the
seven baby steps really quickly because
I've got him here in front of me and the
first one is what ryan talked about here
and I'm interested
CK if these principles if you feel like
they're malleable enough to they would
apply to just about anyone I think so
but of course some additional input
would be nice baby step number one so in
his book the Total Money Makeover he
outlines the details behind these baby
steps number one is save a thousand
dollars for your starter emergency fund
and build a budget so you talked about
budgeting every dollar calm that by the
way is Dave Ramsey's app not an ad we
don't get paid by them to to talk to you
about it it's just what Ryan uses and it
is something that lots new thousands if
not hundreds of thousands before that I
was using a spreadsheet and it was
miserable right and so save a thousand
dollars that's your first step you can't
move on to the next step which is the
next principle until you've saved a
thousand dollars so you have an
emergence of wise Ryan illustrate why
emergency funds is important it's a
peace of mind if your car breaks
down if you have some sort of home
emergency a medical emergency you have
the peace of mind I'm have a thousand
dollars in a separate bank account
savings account that I can't touch and
you know that it's going to be there for
my god for real emergencies I'm talking
I'm thinking about when I was 16 years
old and a car my car would start making
a funny noise
I got instant anxiety of like oh no
those might be the CB boots and those
are gonna cost me $350 I don't have $350
we're like when if I had that thousand
dollar emergency fund I wouldn't I would
not be a stressed out about it it
wouldn't be as devastating but it might
take me five years to do it okay yeah
however long it takes just do it because
the momentum you build towards doing the
right thing will actually make you more
intelligent at recognizing opportunities
to do the right thing even more
effectively and by the way if you're
making $31,000 a year and you might
think a custom stuff out for a while you
you might have to you're not going out
to restaurants for a while right now and
and that's okay you need to get this
emergency fund first because it's going
to give you a solid foundation you're
gonna get out of quicksand right now you
feel like you're in quicksand
because you don't even have an emergency
fund most likely baby step number two is
pay off all debt except your house which
I don't know whether or not you own a
house but if you're renting that's fine
too Holly but step two is pay off all
that except the house using what Dave
Ramsey calls the debt snowball right and
so that's paying lining up all your
debts smallest to largest and the math
doesn't always work perfectly on this
but it gives you the momentum that you
need to keep going so let's say you're
like the average American credit card
who average American who has four credit
cards in their wallet or maybe Holly
you're like one in ten Americans who has
10 or more active criminal ARDS in her
wallet and you would take all ten credit
cards which everyone has a smallest
balance you pay that off first I don't
care if it's $35 but you put your
medical bills in there your student
loans everything else you tackle that
debt now you make the minimum payments
on everything else so if you have 12
debts you make minimum payments on all
of them you pay off the smallest one
first gives you that momentum and you
move on to the next smallest one so
forth and so on
you get that momentum all of a sudden
you get to that last one you're just
throwing all the extra money you have
you're not eating out a restaurant
you're not going to the movies you're
saving money however you can
pay off the debt you've got your
emergency fund baby step two you're
paying off all debts baby step three as
you save you you add on to your
emergency fund three to six months of
expenses and a fully funded emergency
fund so let's say if you make $31,000
and if you're spending all of that then
well you're gonna need fifteen thousand
five hundred dollars somewhere around
there long term now that might take you
a year or longer to save that up and
that's okay but you're gonna keep
working on the baby step you don't work
on these simultaneous so you go from
baby step one to baby step
two to baby step three until you finish
that step baby step four is start
investing at least fifteen percent of
your income
now you can invest more than that
eventually but that is a baseline now
that's that that would apply if you're a
millionaire you save fifteen percent of
a million for making a million bucks a
year you can make a thousand bucks a
year you're saving $150 a year right so
that that principle still holds it's not
saying whatever one needs to invest
$1,000 a month or whatever yeah for sure
so finding 15 percent right and
investing that I I highly recommend
index funds so a place like Vanguard
with really low fees Dave Ramsey
recommends mutual funds the key here is
finding a place to invest your money and
realizing you can't time the market
we're in a time right now where it's
panic season and people pulling their
money on the market you cannot time the
market no you are not a day trader so
don't buy individual stocks don't buy
commodities like like Bitcoin or
precious metals or whatever else these
aren't investments some people who make
it their full-time job to day trade they
can figure this out you don't have to
worry about that personally I put on
money and Vanguard mutual funds you can
go to a place like betterment not a
sponsor but they they will help you I
was or you can go to Vanguard directly
and you can do that or if your your
place of employment whether either the
church you're working out or the
school's you're teaching at now if
either one of them offer a 401k invest
in that because a lot of these 401ks
match that's a great place to put your
money to 401k or Roth IRA if you're
making if you're not making a lot of
money then a Roth IRA is it is post tax
but you're not going to get you know
double-dipped on I can imagine how like
Holly right now listening to this how
stressful it might be for her thinking
about investing any money because maybe
she has a lot of debt but that's why you
got to follow these steps one at a time
because Holly when you like once you get
that a merchant seaman thousand dollars
once you pay off all your debts once you
get your your six months saved up well
now it's a hell of a lot easier to start
don't hurt to start investing yeah
investing fifteen percent of your of
your income when you don't have to worry
about those other things I heard I heard
a preacher once say he said God doesn't
bless you when you obey he blesses you
while you obey and what he meant by that
is the rewards of a good life are not
something that you have to wait for at
the point when you've lived it the
rewards of a good life began once you
get into the rhythm of the process
itself the rhythm itself it's what's
rewarding because that rhythm creates
other opportunities and it begins to
feed on itself so just get in the rhythm
of doing the right things and don't have
the mindset of like I can't experience
the benefits of this until I am
completely done amen
so one more I'll limit this to like max
of maximally oh man
going back to a comment one of the
objections that somebody expressed to
you you may not need a budget in order
to know how poor you are but you do need
a budget in order to know how you're
under estimating the hidden sources of
wealth in your life yeah sweet that
podcast show yeah baby step five is safe
for your children's college fund so I
think it's like a five thirty nine
account if you're gonna send your kids
to college don't have kids totally skip
number six that's what this is 505 oh
you can move two steps then you bypass
that altogether step six is pay off your
home early we are one of two countries
that this would have had this thirty
year now forty year fixed rate mortgages
and it makes me think of doc Christopher
dr. Christopher Ryan he's like isn't it
your goal to like accumulate as much
debt as you can at the end of your life
so when you die for your whole life like
seventy and remember Benny the forty
year mortgage
yes and some of these banks will do it
because that deck gets passed on is the
problem well I mean sort of but not
really does yeah yeah and so so yeah you
want to pay off your home and and the
reason that you want to pay off your
home early is because it is a debt and
there is no such thing as good debt now
there are some debts that are better
than others and so having a house
payment is better than having a cash
loan payment right or having a loanshark
payment right so yes you want to pay off
your house early and number seven is
build wealth and give you know what Dave
Ramsey obviously says is you want to
give like you want to live like no one
else so you can eventually give like no
one else meaning you're gonna have to
get really weird about all of these
things and saving saving your money
spending it more wisely and people are
gonna look at you sometimes like oh
you're not going out to eat with the
rest of us
no I why I'm not saying no to going out
to eat with you I'm saying yes to paying
off this debt and if you reframe it like
that you have a way to you know not that
you have to explain yourself to anyone
but it's empowering to be able to say
here's what I'm doing and I'm I am
unabashedly unapologetically weird
because our society is broken and I'm
tired of being broke as a consequence
what went add-on to the to the notion of
giving giving is like saving it's not
something that you wait until you get
rich to start doing it you got to start
doing it now yeah it takes a discipline
and faith to do it now and yes you may
not be rich but you can customize man
give away a nickle give away a penny
give away time like give away a
thank-you card but find a way to get
into the giving mentality there's a
quote in the Bible that I love so much
that's often misunderstood and
underestimated it says it is better to
give than to receive and I don't think
that's just a statement about the
nobility of being a giver
I believe it's it's it's a piece of
advice on how to really empower your
life
the reason it's better to give than to
receive is because you cannot give from
a consciousness of lack and scarcity in
order to give you have to see yourself
as someone who has something to give so
the very act of giving is one that
transforms your mindset
and causes you to think in terms of
abundance so when you practice giving
you actually increase the odds that you
will recognize opportunities for more
abundance in your life the fastest path
to getting richer is trying to think in
terms of how can I become a habitual
giver dude I love that man because you
don't have to wait till baby step number
seven - yeah yeah I mean yeah you do
have to wait till baby step number seven
to give what is it fifteen percent no
ten percent no it's not well I mean
obviously Dave he recommends giving 10
percent yeah I can give as much this
thing is you can give you can be like
Mike Bloomberg and who is giving away
virtually all of his wealth I mean he's
giving away nearly what is it eighty
billion dollars and you have people like
Bill Gates who are giving away you know
most of their income throughout their
lifetimes before they die yeah and so
you can give away nearly a hundred
percent when you get to these to these
levels and so since we're talking about
sort of economics and economic hardship
tki thought maybe we could finish this
Holly's question by the way Holly will
send you a copy of Total Money Makeover
we hit by on by the case here but Tek
week I figure we could talk about giving
because we we often think that that
someone else is going to give whether
it's it's the government or it is some
other charitable organization and we
often don't think about our own
responsibility to our community and the
people around us to to contribute beyond
ourselves
yeah well the interesting thing about
this topic is that giving is a little
bit like writing a book everybody dreams
of doing it one day most of us just take
that dream to the grave because we're
not able to overcome the resistance
that's involved in the process yeah but
most people say things like man it will
be really nice to have a financial
windfall because we all have an idea in
our minds of who we could help if we won
the lotto but we have this disempowered
assumption this disempowering assumption
that makes us think well I'm never in a
position to give until or unless I have
a whole bunch of money but the
entrepreneurial mindset is the one that
says that thinks in Reverse I'm never in
a position to have money unless I learn
how to become a masterful giver
right like what does it mean to create
wealth other than to create value in
exchange for the wealth that I seek your
aggressively solving other people's
problems
you're as aggressively sold and it takes
a givers mentality because it doesn't
take them in Tala be of saying I'm just
gonna think about what makes me happy
and my fulfillment and I'm gonna ignore
everybody else no if you want to create
wealth you got to say man I need to
humble myself and become a student of
other people what is his brother need
what does the sister over here complain
about all the time
what makes what's making them so unhappy
they look like they're struggling
unnecessarily over that like how can I
come up with an idea how can I use my
gifts and talents in order to solve that
problem for them and and and the reason
you want to go through this process is
not just to create external wealth but
this is a process that causes you to
take your own creativity more seriously
you because I reject this myth that it
takes money to make money it doesn't
take money to make money money is a
symbolic representation of creative
power it takes creative power to make
money and in order to make money what
you have to do is you've got to look
within at your own inner resources your
own intangible assets and you got to say
I've got something maybe the ability to
make people laugh maybe the ability to
cause people to see things differently
maybe the ability to make them feel good
about sales about themselves I've got
something how can I figure out what that
is and do the work necessary to give
that to people from whatever position
I'm in and that's how you get the money
to be the giver that you dream of being
you got to give first I love that dude
that makes me think about how when I
moved to Los Angeles I started just
realizing how there's this wall I have
to push through and so there's a certain
point where I was like okay I'm gonna
give someone the gift of feeling valued
and like that is what and that's what I
do in LA now and it has created so so
many meaningful actions with just random
people because I'm just giving them the
gift of feeling valued we're in a place
like LA it's a very it's a very much
service attitude you're paying you're
tipping you're you know everyone's doing
something for you and and and it's it's
you know sometimes it's a little
disheartening to look at just how the
city operates on on you know valet and
and whatever it may be so when I have to
get my car valeted when I'm getting a
cup of coffee it's like instead of
perpetuating the entitlement
the yeah that's right in min la this is
what la is it's like no no like this la
experience happens because of this
ballet person and going on him a way to
give just someone that that feeling of
being valued it it creates a better
experience for me not just for them but
me also yeah and the more you do it the
better you get at it right there's a
verse in the Bible that says i'ma shut
up real quick Josh there's a verse in
the Bible that says something to the
effect of he that considereth the clouds
shall not sow and he that regardeth the
rain or the wind shall not reap and and
what it means by that is you're never
gonna get the permission from your
circumstances to invest in your life and
to invest in other people you've got to
decide to do that as a fundamental act
of rebellion and when you take when you
exercise that courage that's when you
begin to reap what you sow
because you're sowing with the
permissionless mind yeah I just I love
this conversation because really what I
hope people are getting out of this
people right now who are like I don't
have two nickels to rub together I got
nothing to give that's death that's not
the case you absolutely have a gift to
give people whether it's making people
feel valued whether it's making someone
laugh whatever it is like you have the
power to really get clear on what it is
that you have to give and start giving
that it's going to create yes a better
life for the people that you're giving
that to but it's going to create a
better life for yourself and it will
probably create more wealth for you
long-term as well because as tkm inches
we're talking about expense problems
here right the debt and and and yes if
you're making $31,000 a year you're
you're going to have a harder time with
your expenses there are two ways to
tackle and I think it should be tackled
from both sides the first way is we do
need to reduce our expenses we need to
be more responsible with the money that
we have and that's applicable no matter
where you are in the socio-economic
ladder especially if you have less money
we need to be especially responsible
with with that money and and so TK yeah
I think you would probably argue that if
someone is in poverty they especially
have to be responsible with with the
money that they have and and then also
not just the money but any resource they
have right but then also we can we can
we can make more resources they are not
the pie is not is not limited right and
so Holly Matt making thirty one thousand
dollars a year it doesn't mean that
that's what you're going to make forever
if you're able to aggressively help
people solve problems you're gonna have
the opportunity to make more money is
that is that accurate
that's absolutely right one of my
favorite pieces of advice ever received
comes from a real estate investment guru
Peter Daniels who said over the course
of your lifetime Rhea dolls and
biographies because in doing so you will
build a vast vocabulary of overcoming
incredible odds James Baldwin to
paraphrase said you know I thought my
troubles made me unique in the world but
then I began to read and when I began to
understand the stories of other people I
realized that my troubles were part
we're one link in a chain that connected
me to all of humanity you've got to
study the lives of other people because
if you don't the devil will trick you
into thinking that you are the first
person in history to ever struggle with
that particular problem and the reality
is there are people that have come
before you and there are people who will
do it after you who went from a state of
no money to having a lot of money
because they were willing to exercise
the faith necessary to take their
creative power seriously before the rest
of the world did theirs yeah now is it
Holly's responsibility to increase her
income or someone else's responsibility
to increase her income so first and
foremost it's Holly's responsibility
just like it is each of our
responsibilities to feed her spirit to
feed her mind the kind of information
that is going to sell her on the notion
of her personal power you've got to
believe that you have the permission and
the power to be the predominant creative
force in your own life if you don't
believe that you've got to start working
on that belief system because that
belief system is not gonna make you a
winner in your own life its sight
feeding so yeah it starts with that
success mindset and and and you know the
responsibility thing is interesting I
heard Wayne Dyer once say responsibility
does not equal blame it means the power
to respond with ability so when I say
Holly it's your responsibility to create
wealth in your life that doesn't mean
Holly it's your fault that you that
you're in this financial situation or
Holly you're a bad person for not having
the money that you want it's a way of
saying Holly understand that you have
the power no matter where you are in
life to respond to your particular
unique situation with ability you may
have some things to learn you may have
to exercise from patient but patience
but you can do it because there are
people who are worse off who have to go
on
for you and done it I know there are
people out there who like they'll read
something or listen to something Josh
and I do and they're like oh but Josh
and I they just don't understand well
maybe we don't understand but there are
people out there who do understand and
find those people and learn from their
understanding of your situation but
there are there is I think somewhat in
the zeitgeist these days there's a bit
of a defeatist attitude and say well yes
that person could do it but I can't why
is that permeated our our sort of
knowledge yeah you know I get that I'm
not unsympathetic towards that you know
it's easy it's easy to give up I think
yeah and and and when the hero's being
held up as examples are are unlike you
it can make it a little more difficult
to believe in these possibilities for
yourself this is why I believe the power
of story is so important this is why I
value the advice about reading a
thousand biographies or exposing
yourself to stories because we don't
learn through abstract advice you got to
do better you should save more we learn
from the stories of people who look like
us who come from the places that we come
from and I do think it's important to
have a diverse range of role models of
communicators of educators and so and by
the way that's one thing that we can all
give if you feel like you got nothing to
give give your mentorship to someone who
looks like you who may not have
experienced a little bit of joy in life
that you've experienced but I think
that's part of the problem but here's
what I would say in response to anyone
that feels like that I get it maybe
you're right maybe maybe you are the
only person who understands you but my
question to you is this
what's that belief gonna do for you you
could you can stop there and be right or
you can alter that belief and you can
get what you want right what do you want
to do do you want to be right or do you
want to get what you want do you want to
be right in your suffering or do you
want to step into the power that can
create you a life that transcends that
suffering here's the other thing that I
would say the more unique your problems
are the more unique your testimony will
be right so if you are the first person
to experience whatever kind of suffering
you're going through that means when you
figure this out and overcome it you are
going to have a unique story to tell
that nobody has ever told before I love
you're the only one with that problem
you're gonna be the only one with that
testimony and man please don't rob the
world of that
there's gonna be great wealth in that
testimony because you just proved it no
one else has had that problem no one
else's saw bit you're about to make
history yeah just don't give up I love
that person it is it's like you can look
at it from that perspective or you can
look at him like oh poor me I can't do
anything because I have this unique
problem and it's both or true it isn't
an in it and it isn't as indra Schultz
would say I'm really really close to
being a President of the United States
but I'm black ain't nobody ever been in
this situation with that problem before
what else why you about to make history
run don't do that yeah yeah we got so
much more to talk about we're gonna skip
the lightning round today but if you do
have questions for us send us a text
message nine three seven two oh two four
six five four those text messages go
right to Ryan's and my phone we try to
respond to as many people via text as we
can but we also answer some of our
favorites during the lightning round on
the podcast but for the sake of time
we're gonna skip that because we got a
bunch more to talk about I'm gonna try
to get to most of these questions Ryan
what are the wisest investments to make
in my early 20s to retire by my early
30s so we can talk about some of the the
fire community wisdom there also how do
I determine at what point financially it
makes sense to get rid of the car I owe
money on so card debt such a big
question so many people want to know
about another question how do we
appropriately help the homeless that are
struggling to get back on their feet
probably the most difficult question
we're gonna talk about it doesn't make
economic sense to get rid of my car and
rely on public transportation I'm gonna
give you an argument argument for both
sides of that does it makes economic
sense to purchase a tiny home how do i
reconcile my desire for charitable
giving with a restrictive budget does it
make economic sense to rent a car like I
rent an apartment and also why are local
governments resistant to allowing the
presence of more economical minimalist
abodes like tiny houses and RVs where I
talk more about regulation oh man you
knew we'd get back to 80k so that's
something that just enrages me Ryan I
have not been enraged like this in a
wise in New York Times article he has
17,000 bottles of hand sanitizer hand
sanitizer and nowhere to sell them
here's the the byline
Amazon cracked down on coronavirus price
gouging now while the rest of the world
searches some sellers are holding stock
piles of sanitizer and masks we're going
to talk about that now part of long
story short serves him right
jerks well part of me wants to get into
my car with Ryan and podcast Sean and
drive to Chattanooga Tennessee
and put this guy's head on a curb
politically politically yes
metaphorically yes so josh has anyone
said metaphorically curb stomp this guy
yeah I'm not saying literally but I
would love to politically put his teeth
on the curb Oh Mike we're gonna regulate
this brother metaphorically talk about
my rage that I feel towards I were to
read this article and if you wanna hear
all that listen to this week's maximal
episode Ryan and I every week in our
guests we record a a much longer much
more personal much deeper episode is
called the maximal episode it's on the
minimalist private podcast and it's just
two dollars but that two dollars goes a
long way it pays for Sean and in Jordan
and Jessen and me and Ryan our studio
space and our equipment and all of our
families because we're a hundred percent
advertisement free we think
advertisements suck and this is the best
way for us to fund this podcast and it's
a completely separate endeavor it's the
minimalist private podcast which you're
able to play in your regular podcast app
so if you have like overcast or Apple
podcast or whatever you use you can we
give you a separate private feed for the
minimalist private podcast and there's
just two bucks but that goes a long way
to keep this podcast a hundred percent
advertisement free you can find all the
details to that and including an
additional private podcast episode every
week over at the minimalists com slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
this week we got some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners let's check
them out hey guys this is Nicky from
Mount Pleasant South Carolina I just
listened to your podcast called media
and I actually had an app recommendation
I do have an Android but I'm pretty sure
there's an iOS and iPhone app out there
that's similar
it's called app detox and I love it
because it allows
to restrict and even block access to
apps on your phone so I personally use
it for Facebook and Instagram and I
allow myself a 30-minute time limit each
day but at times especially when I find
myself getting lost in the infinite
scroll of the news feeds I'll actually
block access completely so I think that
it has added a lot of values of my life
and I think can add value to a lot of
other listeners lives as well I wanted
to call in to share a recent revelation
that I had which has removed numerous
roadblocks that have come up against on
my quest for a more minimalist lifestyle
the Public Library I hadn't been to the
public library since about high school
and I can't believe I had forgotten all
of the free resources available at my
local library that previously I had been
routinely and wastefully paying for
movies and movie rentals magazines and
magazine subscriptions books many of
which if I decided to purchase and not
rent lingered around in my house
collecting dust until I got around to
minimizing them even the due date on the
materials I get from the library now is
helpful it motivates me to complete the
book or magazine in timely manner
allowing me to fit in more information
over time which I enjoy since I tend to
mosey through those items if I own them
in my interest often grows cold
I'm saving even by having a quiet well
lighted location with plenty of space
and outlets to do work something I had
actually been paying money for by
working in places where a Starbucks or
Barnes and Noble where I felt pressured
to purchase a coffee or snack in
exchange for the work location I don't
have those pressures at the library
which is good for my wallet and my
health in fact I realized I was actually
losing money by not using the library
since the tax dollars that I necessarily
pay were going toward the upkeep of the
library which I was not utilizing I
encouraged I encouraged all of those who
are looking for a more minimalist
lifestyle but who don't want to
sacrifice the luxury of indulging in
printed or digital media in a pleasant
workspace outside of the home to
rediscover their public library and
other free offerings in their community
something that's simple and easy alright
y'all before we get out of
today I want to say thank you to TK : TK
I want to encourage folks to check you
out
TK : calm they can check you out feet
org I believe it is feet org slash rev 1
okay rev 1 is the [ __ ] is TK : show but
most important follow his Twitter feed
because if you're if you're looking for
someone to follow who has just thoughts
that are a bit against the grain but
also that he's my favorite person to
disagree with you want someone to every
face to hate so check out CK Coleman
he's TK underscore Coleman on Twitter
we'll put a link to all of that in the
show notes as well I just want to say
thank you and acknowledge you for doing
something amazing thank you so much TK
thanks guys know what I love about you
TK is you really push what I value and
what I believe and you you help me
either come towards your side or you
really help me to dig deeper on why I
feel the way I feel and that is a true
talent because we can have a
conversation we can have even you know a
rational argument and we can still you
know give you well we won't give each
other hugs now because of the
coronavirus but we could still give each
other a hug afterwards under normal
[Laughter]
circumstances if you go to the middle
lists calm /resources I'm there right
now we have a bunch of free resource for
you we talk about economic hardship
today and we don't want finances to be
the the barrier so Ryan I have a bunch
of free resources on our website in
addition to our free newsletter we have
a simple Sunday newsletter you can sign
up for free we send you an email with
some minimalism tips or just minimalism
essays different writings about simple
living intentional living every week
over the minimalists calm slash
resources you can also get our podcast
show notes in your inbox for frees all
the things we talked about you can get
those right there over there on our
website we have a free ebook called the
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less everything from our photo
scanning rule to our minimalist
gift-giving rule this free book ebook
will help you simplify your life
rule at a time we have the 30-day
minimalism game calendar we have six
free minimalist wallpapers and actually
we're adding a seventh one this month
you can't change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
could put one on each of your seven
screens do we got to talk about a max or
minimal maximum Monday's - so how do
people sign up for that yeah so if you
text us you just text us whatever you
want they put me on your your text
message list so every Monday if you if
you just if you if you're on our text
list nine three seven two oh two four
six five four you can text those
questions there but also every Monday we
send out minimal maxims just Monday
morning mineral maximum so a way to
start your week with just a little
thought provoking one-line minimal Maxim
and so you can do that just by texting
us also you can find some minimus home
tours over on the free resources page
the values worksheet get in touch with
your values and a whole bunch of other
resources there the minimalists comm
slash resources and our added value this
week oh by the way you can follow us on
on social media if you want at the
minimalists twitter facebook instagram
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com slash the minimalist but for
our added value this week Ryan someone
just sent me this song this morning on
Twitter and you know people send songs
but it was a perfect song we're talking
about economics and how we get so caught
up in sort of consumerism we're spending
money on the wrong things and so this
song is called personal shopper it's by
a guy named Steven Wilson and I love the
album title it's a forthcoming album
it's called the future bites and this
reminds me a bit of Radiohead I'll play
a bit here at the the end of the episode
but I love these first two stanzas of
the song here the lyrics have now have
now pay in another life kickstart the
future except this loan fill in the form
you're pre-qualified now you're you are
the sum of what you own by now by now
have a better life close out
transactions without remorse apply for
credit it's you're given right by it all
than buy some more
and that seems to be these the maximum
that we live by the sort of motto is by
now don't worry about it now my future
self will take care of it but but
today's indiscretions today's bad
decisions are going to be paid for only
by your future self and so keep that in
mind your future self will also benefit
by having the right decisions made today
so I hope you enjoy the song from Steven
Wilson this is called personal shopper
and if you live here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time